مصطفى يعني دمار هائل يعني
حتى يضيع عن فم التعبير لاصف هذا حجم
الدمار وحجم يعني الكارثه منذ خمسه ايام
ساترك لك الكلمه تفضل مصطفى
كما تشاهد الان هذه الفرق المعنيه ايضا
باعاده تاهيل الطريق على يساري امامي
تماما في الصوره ربما الان صار اصبحت
مشاهده من قبل الكوم على الشاشه
جرافات مدحله ايضا كذلك ايضا مركبه تحمل
على جلب الحصى من اجل الكبس الدفع الطريق
المجددا من اجل اعاده ترميمه كمسار اولي
ومن ثم يقوم بهذا التعميره ترميم الطرف
الاخر لكن ساضطر للخروج من هنا
هذا التصدعات الان في الطريق واضحه التي
اتحرك عليها هنا خطر جدا يعني لو شاهدت
هنا
مصطفى ارجو ان تلتزم الحذر يعني لانه يعني
انت يعني ان تمشي على هذه على هذا الاسفلت
المدمر والمتشققي مثلا
جدا ولكن كي يرى المشاهد حجم الدمار الذي
تهدد حياتك ارجوك ان شاء الله لا لا ابدا
لا لا ابدا ضمن الاحتياطات الواجبه وهنالك
منازل على يميني كي اريك اياها ايضا طبعا
الاسفلت طبقه تقريبا حوالي 30 الى 35 سم
كما تشاهد هذا الانهيار هنا على يساري
تماما
لو ذهبت بالكاميرا هكذا الان
معدات التقنيه بسيطه ولكن الصوره توضح
اكثر من اللسان يعجز عنها اللسان كما
تشاهد هذا الانهيار هنا الانهيار داخل
قرابه
داخل الطريق
هنا تشاهد الان هذه الابنيه التي تحدثت
عنها قبل قليل بجانب مزرعه تشاهد هنا
هنغار انقلب بشكل كامل وعلى الطرف الاخر
هنا هذه اللوحات الارشاديه هذه اللوحه
تشير الى ان مدينه انطاكيا على مسافه
قريبه او
ليست واضحه بالنسبه لي باشا هذه المنطقه
هذه المنطقه على يساري اسمها حجي باشا هذا
الانهيار هنا واضح ايضا هنا الطرف الاخر
على زفلت الذي امشي عليه الطرف هذا اليمين
كما تشاهد هنالك العربات هنالك ايضا
المعدات التقنيه التي جلبت لاجله مباني
متصدعه مباني مائله
كما تشاهد طيب مصطفى في هذه